[Music]
very show was so groundbreaking Mary
with their own person he was a single
woman on her own in a strange city
throwing her beret in the air I remember
there was one saying it was some Annette
fenberry was was Mary's mother and my
father all bill was so what's her father
and Annette turned around and said to
said that the two of them don't forget
don't forget your pill and Bill said I
won't and Mary said I won't and there
was like whoa when was the last time you
talked to her there was something in the
trades that Betty White and I were going
to do something together and I got a
call she said if you ever do anything
together I want to be proud what will
you miss most about Mary her smile I
think what a great spot huh if you could
give a message to her just about what
she meant to you in your career what
would you say probably what millions of
people are saying right now thank you
Newhart was just one of several of
Moores collaborators who reflected on
her life and legacy a longtime on-screen
husband Dick Van Dyke tweeted there are
no words she was the best we always said
that we changed each other's lives for
the better
you
[Music]